[Musique]
voilà pas mal ça va je peux y mettre un
peu plus loin comme ça
bonjour sylvie kauffmann chaud et merci
de nous accorder cet entretien alors
cette épidémie de coronavirus elle
bouleverse évidemment tout sur son
passage y compris la géopolitique etats
unis chine europe on va en parler dans
le détail mais d'abord est-ce que vous
avez été surprise de voir qu'on n'a pas
pu répondre au niveau mondial à cette
crise ni au niveau du g20 du g7 ni au
niveau des nations unies c'est une
surprise ou pas pas vraiment parce que
ce qu'on peut dire de 7,2 de la
géopolitique de cette crise ou des
conséquences géopolitiques de cette
crise dans un premier temps c'est que
elle elle a accéléré cette crise a
vraiment accélérer de manière très
brutale est assez choquante mais des
tendances qui était déjà à l'oeuvre dans
dans l'ordre international mondial s'il
voulait on voyait bien déjà avant la
crise que cet ordre international qui
est hérité de la deuxième guerre
mondiale en fait qui l'ordre organisé
par les les états unis au 20ème siècle
était déjà très mal en point que la
mondialisation était critiquée que l'onu
avait énormément de mal à fonctionner
que le conseil de sécurité étaient
bloqués sur la syrie de manière
permanente
que le g7 ne marchait pas très bien en
plus le g20 faisait à peu près sans
effet mais que l'om c était aussi un peu
en panne voilà on avait déjà un
phénomène qui était très visible et
qu'on analyse et beaucoup de noms pas de
désagrégation mais de détérioration très
nettes de l'ordre international donc
voilà le choc la violence du choc de
cette de cette pandémie
a vraiment accentué tout ça
mais c'est assez spectaculaire cela la
déflagration générale est vraiment
spectaculaire autre nouveauté avec cette
crise c'est qu'elle a été gérée pour
partie par des pouvoirs populiste donald
trump jaillir bol somaro poutine or ban
alors pouvoir autoritaire aussi est ce
que ça change quelque chose dans la
possibilité d'une réponse coordonnée
mondiale de toute façon y avoir un
moment où politiquement il va falloir
rendre des comptes et on va établir une
sorte de deux tableaux de qui a qui a
réussi quel régime a bien fonctionné
quel régime on a mal fonctionné et
évidemment cela va se faire suivant des
critères qui ne sont pas forcément les
critères classiques de de qualité ou en
tout cas nos critères démocratiques à
nous c'est à dire on voit que la chine
se targue d'avoir bien gérer sa crise
puisque le nombre de morts en chine est
bien bien bien inférieur au nombre de
morts aux etats-unis ou en europe en
réalité
on ne sait pas si la chine a vraiment
bien gérer sa crise d'abord parce qu'on
ne sait pas si les chiffres qu'elle lui
fournit sont exactes et ensuite il ya
quand même ses doutes énorme sur
l'origine de l'épidémie qui est parti de
chine on ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé
dans ses laboratoires de gourin donc là
pour l'instant il ya une opacité qui est
qui est une caractéristique des régimes
autoritaires mais qui nous empêche de
voir vraiment ce qui s'est passé la
grande surprise c'est la faiblesse de la
première puissance mondiale
donald trump s'est révélé incapable de
gérer de façon efficace cette crise il a
pris des mauvaises décisions il avait
coupé les crédits de la recherche il a
il a même remis en cause le bureau d
épidémie avant la crise et voilà que
tous les emplois créés avant la crise
ont détruit plus de 20 millions de
chômeurs en une semaine c'est ça au fond
de bilan de trump c'est une grande
faiblesse voire un désastre alors il y à
il y a deux choses il y a le modèle
américain et il y à la gestion
par son parent le président donald trump
alors la gestion para par donald trump
vous venez de la décrire elle est
effectivement assez catastrophique en
tout cas vu vu d'europe au début il a
commencé par minimiser la maladie il a
dit que c'était une grippe il a dit que
ça serait terminée très rapidement qui
auraient zéro mort il a été obligé de
changer de stratégie ensuite il s'est
disputé avec les gouverneurs notamment
celui de new york celui de californie et
ceux dont les états étaient les plus
touchés on a assisté même à une crise du
fédéralisme américain d'une certaine
manière parce qu'on a un président qui
appelle qui encourage des manifestants à
se révolter contre leurs gouverneurs
avant donc on a en effet une gestion je
ne parle pas des épisodes où le
président a même suggéré qu'on pouvait
s'injecter du désinfectant ainsi puisque
ça marchait pour pour nettoyer les
surfaces enfin voilà donc on a en effet
une un président en actions qui pose
énormément de problèmes avec des
conséquences assez lourdes pour son pays
et puis on a un modèle américain
qui en effet révèle ses faiblesses et
pas la première fois on l'a vu déjà
pendant la crise financière de 2008
c'est-à-dire que dès que l'économie
accuse un gros choc on a immédiatement
des millions de chômeurs des gens qui
sont licenciés du jour au lendemain qui
ont beaucoup moins de protection et
d'indemnisation que nous l'avons en
europe il n'y a pas de filet de sécurité
sociale à proprement parler aux états
unis il perdre son assurance maladie
quand vous êtes en pleine épidémie c'est
assez dramatique sur le plan humain donc
là on a je pense que ça c'est quelque
chose qui va qui va avoir des
conséquences assez lourdes
est ce que pour revenir à la
géopolitique
les états unis et donald trump doivent
se donner un nouvel ennemi alors
peut-être qu'il l'était déjà mais là il
ya une mise en scène de l'ennemi à
travers la chine donald trump décide de
parler du virus chinois de marteler
cette expression pour aussi retrouver
une certaine forme de puissance face à
la vulnérabilité du modèle américain oui
bien sûr il ya cette il y à 7 cette idée
de d'attaquer la chine pour trouver un
peu pour essayer de comme dérivatif
d'une certaine manière pour masquer ses
propres erreurs de gestion mais comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure cette crise
accélère les tendances déjà à l'oeuvre
sur le plan international et la rivalité
la compétition et l'affrontement
sino-américain entre la chine et les
états unis était déjà une réalité du
monde pré crise donc là on voit cette
cette compétition s'exacerber avec la
montée en puissance de la chine qui
essayent de manière très spectaculaire
et très visible de se servir de cette
crise pour montrer
que son modèle est le plus efficace et
le meilleur et vous montrer cette vidéo
regardez
11h55
kostelic
ça veut dire quoi ça c'est complètement
nouveau alors c'est pas complètement
nouveau mais c'est beaucoup plus
spectaculaire est beaucoup plus
accentuée que ce que ce que ce qu'on
avait vu avant c'est à dire que déjà
avant voyez que la chine
surtout depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
cieszyn team
avait quitté sept disques cette
stratégie de d'ascension discrète qui
était en réalité là la stratégie
initiale de dunks xiaoping là on voit
que la chine veut faire de cette crise
une opportunité
ce qui est amusant parce que le mot
crise en chinois veut aussi dire
opportunité donc là on est vraiment dans
la logique chinois une certaine manière
et montrer que la chine a un modèle
supérieur à celui des etats unis et
comme les états unis sous la conduite de
donald trump sont en retrait sur le plan
international on voit bien là là
vraiment lieu dans cette crise les
etats-unis ont abandonné toute
prétention au leadership mondial il ne
s'en occupe même plus ils ont tourné le
dos aux alliés européens dès le début de
la crise en fermant les frontières sans
même les alerter ils ont suspendu
leur financement à l'om est-ce
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
logiquement devrait être l'organisation
internationale la plus importante en ce
moment pour la communauté mondiale donc
on est vraiment là dans une compétition
féroce
de ces deux modèles et la chine essaye
d'en tirer le meilleur parti ça veut
dire que les chinois le projet de pékin
c'est d'exploiter les difficultés des
européens à également alors je pense pas
que ce soit un projet mais c'est un
moyen ils ont ils en profitent ils en
tirent parti ils voient que le modèle
américain est affaibli ils voient que
les états unis sont absents de la scène
internationale ils voient que l'europe
est en grande difficulté dans cette
crise sanitaire est donc en effet il
déploie cet outil qui est qu'on appelle
matkal à la diplomatie d'ue la
diplomatie du masque en disant voilà
nous on peut vous apporter de l'aide
humanitaire ça n'est pas de l'aide en
général c'est payé c'est payant mais il
en est en effet il en tire le mais le
plus grand parti possible sur le plan de
la propagande alors ça n'est pas
totalement nouveau non plus ce qui est
nouveau c'est l'intensité
le sixième ping a déployé cette
stratégie des routes de la soie des
nouvelles routes de la soie depuis déjà
quelques années qu'ils sont qui sont en
réalité un déploiement
d'infrastructures et de financement
d'infrastructures à travers le monde
avec des prêts financiers avec eux c'est
une stratégie d' influence en réalité et
une partie de ces routes de la soie
s'appelait les routes de la soie la
route de la soie de la santé oms n'y
avait pas tellement fait attention parce
que en effet les pandémies n'était
malheureusement pas la priorité de nos
préoccupations
maintenant je crois que on peut vraiment
douté du succès de cette stratégie elle
est impressionnante elle est
spectaculaire
est-ce que ça va marcher je pense que
c'est vraiment c'est une stratégie à
double tranchant parce que quand vous
exposez beaucoup vous exposez beaucoup
aussi à ce qu'on vous regardez à ce
qu'on scrute que vous êtes en train de
faire et à ce qu'on essaye d'enquêter
sur voila on voit bien avec tout ce
qu'on essaie de savoir sur l'origine de
ce virus alors face à ces deux géants
etats unis chine il ya l'europe il ya
l'europe qui peine à trouver sa place
sur le plan géopolitique est ce qu'on
peut dire qu'elle est pour l'heure la
grande perdante dans cette crise vous
avez tout à fait raison l'essence même
du projet européen est mise en cause par
cette crise c'est à dire en effet vous
avez deux piliers deux des principaux
piliers sur lesquels repose l'union
européenne qui ont été attaqués le
marché unique et l'espace schengen le
marché unique parce qu'on a vu des pays
et pas des moindres la france
l'allemagne et mettre dès le début de la
crise des interdictions d'exportation de
matériel médical au sein de l'union
européenne et puis l'espace schengen
comme vous l'avez dit il y à plus d'une
douzaine de pays qui ont fermé qui ont
fermé leurs frontières à un moment ou un
autre pas la france d'ailleurs il faut
le remarquer mais l'allemagne par
exemple le 15 mars a fermé ses
frontières avec cinq pays dont la france
il y avait une frontière en alsace pour
la première fois depuis très longtemps
donc elle là il ya vraiment eu
une grosse question sur qu'est ce que
c'est que l'europe à quoi ça sert quelle
est sa fragilité 6 au premier choc le
réflexe de tous les gouvernements c'est
l'état nation et non pas l'europe
emmanuel macron a toujours appelé de ses
voeux l'europe qui protège l'europe qui
protège la elle n'était vraiment pas au
rendez vous et la faillite dernière
question très rapidement et pour vous
mouiller un peu à quoi il ressemblera
cet ordre monde allah après il y à des
critères qui évolue
par exemple en effet les pays qui ont le
mieux géré cette crise vont gagner en
influence en gagner en soft power vont
gagner en images et je crois que on
parle on parlait déjà beaucoup avant de
la compétition entre régimes
autoritaires et démocratie libérale on
voyait que les démocraties libérales
était à la peine d'une certaine manière
parce qu'on assistait à cette montée du
populisme et des du nationalisme et et
de l'autoritarisme et des leaders forts
mais finalement je crois qu'on voit que
les leaders forts ne se sont pas mieux
débrouillé que les démocraties libérales
que
la chine par exemple a dû mettre en
place un système de surveillance de
masse absolument impressionnant qui fait
penser à un enfant dont on a dit qu'il
était à bord ou et liens
qui ne fait aucune envie aux démocraties
libérales nous ne sommes pas nous ne
sommes pas faits de la même manière nos
régimes sont différents et finalement
ils ont ils montrent une résilience qui
relève du consensus qui je crois va être
un critère qui comptera beaucoup aussi
merci sylvie kauffmann pour ce tour
d'horizon
géopolitique d'aujourd'hui et de demain
au revoir